bien bonsoir
je suis jean pierre rioux quelques-uns
d'entre vous me connaissent peut-être je
suis dans le civil historien
je vous présente les deux amis qui nous
font l'amitié de venir ici en toute
liberté
expliquer ce qu'est leur travail ce
qu'est leur réflexion
sur
le sujet
qui a été choisie qui n'est pas le plus
gratifiant mais
pour reconstruire bien sûr i il faut un
élan ils vont retrousser les manches et
les plus anciens d'entre nous savent ce
qu'a été ce pays après la libération
tout manches retroussées oui il faut des
outils il faut des bonnes truelle et
dans ces outils il faut et les
précédents intervenants l'ont bien fait
sentir il faut avoir les mots pour le
dire
les mots pour montrer qu'on a
l'intelligence de leur réalité et du
présent et que on est prêt par par les
mots à agir
et du coup
nous avons choisi d'ouvrir cette
université de rentrée avec un mot assez
terrible un mode actualité autour duquel
nous allons tourner ce soir
fracturé
c'est pas un mot habituel
et si on entend le bruissement de
l'actualité quelle qu'elle soit qu'elles
soient médiatique qu'elle soit éditorial
qu elle soit un peu scientifique aussi
voilà un mot qui
s'impose qui s'est imposé depuis pas si
longtemps depuis les cinq à dix ans
peut-être
et sur lequel qu'est ce qu'on nous dit
où que nous dit on aujourd'hui
alors le discours il est bien connu et
port pour moi historien il est tout à
fait frappant c'est un discours de
rupture
il n'ya plus d'antécédents il n'y a plus
de cause il n'y a plus d'effet il ya
plus de conséquences il y a des
fractures
arrière hier alors qu'elle était hier il
y avait la glorieuse france républicaine
de la liberté de l'égalité de la
fraternité
il y avait un pays bien sûr qu'ils
engendraient sans cesse des inégalités
qui sortait
victorieux ou non de guerre qui sortait
de guerre franco-française qui
oui accompli c'est une sorte de de vote
de devoir ou de vocations
belliqueuse un pays
est attisée car nous sommes un état un
pays stats au centre et oui c'est ainsi
depuis depuis des siècles des siècles un
pays qui était oui est attisée mai
unitaire voilà
et qui partout toujours savait exprimer
et terreau territorialisée une
souveraineté souveraineté au bout du
compte la souveraineté républicaine la
souveraineté du peuple souveraineté de
qui vous voulez après la souveraineté
des rois
et qu'ils étaient capables
dans ce dispositif
stats au centre et qu'ils étaient
capables de négocier constamment qu'ils
étaient capables de mettre en route des
mécanismes de
rétribution
qu'ils étaient capables de politique du
cliché je te donne ça mais tu me donnes
ça en échange nous pas jusqu'au fond des
dernières communes et qu'ils étaient
capables depuis 1945 avec l'avènement de
ce qu'on appelle l'état providence qui
était capable de re distribution
du fifty fifty je dus me donne et je te
donne et juteux je te donne
est autrement dit la redistribution et
est devenu je dirais la forme étatique
moderne de du contrat social finalement
et
les trente glorieuses
après 1945
ils ont jusqu aux années 1980 ont
évidemment donner le coup de pouce
d'accès l'accélération de tout cela avec
la croissance le mieux-être etc
et
les outils de cette
de cet état d'hyères de ce pays d'hyères
c'était
une administration
c'était une école
c'était un service national
c'était du fisc
voyez quel bataillon était un plant
l'installation de l'impôt sur le revenu
dans ce pays
et c'était et c'était dans le mécanisme
politique de redistribution et de
guichet pour dire les choses méchamment
c'était des élus c'était des élus qui
n'était plus exclusivement des notables
à l'ancienne des élus républicains
qui ont tant fait pour mettre en route
ce mécanisme la qui a fonctionné c'est
vrai jusque jusque jusqu'à la fin des
trente glorieuses
alors aujourd'hui les disques au
domicile pourrait devenir dominants et
de dire tout ça c'est fini
brusquement on rompt avec la temporalité
on vend rompt avec la continuité et
qu'est ce qui lie à aujourd'hui sous nos
yeux des fractures
et des fractures à tous les étages et
faire très attention à ce mot et nous
nos amis vont sûrement s'expliquer sur
lui de tout à l'heure
parce que il voulait le prendre au sens
je dirais
médicale aux cliniques du terne
qui dit fracture dix accidents
et s'ils ont des accidents ont dit que
le cours d'une société le cours d'une
une politique le court que d'une
république le gourmand est pas si
peut-être par un acte accident
bien
et
toujours la métaphore médicale
dès qu'il ya accident il faut courir aux
urgences dès qu'il ya fracture il faut
courir aux urgences pour la réduire le
plus vite possible
autrement dit
c'est l'irruption à travers ce mot de
l'accidentel de le de la tempe or
atemporel a trait d'union temporel
c'est une rupture de la chaîne passé
présent avenir
c'est
réduisons à tout prix quitte à le faire
de façon brouillonne et pas tout à fait
réfléchie et pas tout à fait avec les
mots qui conviennent
réduisons parce qu'il ya urgence sans
s'interroger trop plus avant sur les
maladie de langueur raté spa ou sur
l'élasticité des cartilages de
conjugaison
et ça alors je laisse libre nos invités
de l'est
de réagir tout à l'heure bien sûr ça
c'est quelque chose qui à mon sens
est grave et et menaçant parce que vous
voyez bien ça entretient tout les toutes
les fébrilités toutes les inconséquences
et tout alors cela dit fracture n'est
pas un mot tout à fait nouveau un rap
l'on ne s'était pas tout à fait de
glorieuse mémoire mais quand même la
fracture sociale tels que là nous là
nous l'a présenté jacques chirac en 1995
rappelons quand même les fractures
françaises
telles que
surtout nicolas sarkozy est un peu
françois hollande nous les on dit en
et aujourd'hui
au fond sous fracture que met-on mais
bien sûr des fractures sociales très
bien l'idée que homo inégalités il faut
substituer celui de fracture et dans
tous les domaines observable même pas où
dans tous les domaines où les gens
souffrent bon
que ce soit le logement que ce soit la
santé que ce soit l'éducation que ce
soit la culture que ce soit la
consommation et que ce soit bien sûr
l'emploi
mais on peut y ajouter tout dans les
revenus la qualité de la vie etc ou le
développement durable pourquoi pas
et cette fracture sociale ou ce qu'on
nous en dit se caractérise bien sûr par
un affaissement voie rue pour certains
un affaissement à peu près définitive
des classes moyennes très bien et la
marginalisation de des classes
populaires non
et avec au milieu
je dirais de tout cela une
un jeune âge une
répartition territoriale de la question
des fractures qui va nous intéresser
maintenant
au fond à la fracture sociale
correspondrait une fracture territoriale
qui opposerait
sans qu'elles se rencontrent jamais d'un
côté les métropoles
qui profite à plein ils sont en plein
dans la globalisation etc etc
et qui s'en sortent
des banlieues
quartiers difficiles ou pas peu importe
mais des banlieues qui sont raccrochés à
la métropolisation des choses voilà
et puis tout le reste tout le reste
du rural survivants du père et rural pas
très sûr de lui même du périurbain
bon du périlleux rage voilà du
des
classes ou des groupes reliquat très
bien
et
de 7 ses fractures sociales aux
fractures territoriales
on passe insensiblement pas aux
fractures politiques
qui expliquerait à la fois
la difficulté que nous avons à gérer
notre feuilleter
administrative institutionnel que ce n
est pas comme une région des parties
communes départements régions
qui expliquerait les incohérences ou les
appros poule où les les a priori ou
l'absence de de direction claire de
l'autorité centrale et de l'état pour
tout dire sur la réforme territoriale
telle qu'on nous l'a présenté del conde
va nous l'imposé bientôt et puis surtout
surtout
c'est dans cette france du reste cette
france à l'arrêt cette france fracturée
mais pourtant on ne sait pas réduire les
fractures
que j je dirais le l'avenir électoral du
front national nuance bleu marine et un
bleu marine
alors voilà ce qu'on nous dit
aujourd'hui
parce que on ne saurait plus
freiné au nom de l'égalité on ne saurait
plus redistribuer ou en tout cas les
mécanismes de redistribution ne
fonctionnerait plus autant qu'avant et
parce que au fond et je reprends
l'expression chez notre collègue hamida
beuzit dans une note récente de la
fondation terra nova
on ne sait plus lié
performance et solidarité
et du coup ça donne un pays
soi-disant ou authentiquement fracturée
alors je n'en dis pas plus pour
l'instant
nos invités sont philippe estève
qui est géographe et politistes qui est
professeur à l'institut d'études
politiques de paris et aux plongées
sausset il est directeur là je ne sais
pas la chronique
à il a été viré il va nous dire pourquoi
ça ça augure mal de votre intervention
dire que
oui c'est vrai
dac et alors il est directeur d'un
acronyme je ne suis absolument pas ce
que ça veut dire ça s'appelle 10h le tat
eux c'est un institut on peut le dire
comme ça très bien alors surtout plus
important pour nous au fond
son travail le plus accessible peut-être
c'est ce fonds se devait être votre
thèse qui est paru aux puf en 2008 ça
s'appelle gouverner la ville mobile
intercommunalités et démocratie locale
et libé stebe a beaucoup travaillé sur
l'état sécuritaire sur les huit
nouvelles sur l' usage des quartiers sur
l'élaboration des projets de territoire
sur l'évaluation des politiques
publiques je crois qu'il a travaillé pas
loin d'ici et à brest et à nantes et à
paris
et il est très spécialisés ce que c'est
que la polarisation sociale de l'urbain
finalement est ce que c'est que la
gestion des services des publics
xavier dejardin
qui est maître de conférences à
rien
beaucoup travaillé sur la ville en
morceaux
tout ce qui est ghetto et ségrégation a
beaucoup travaillé sur les transports
urbains aussi et avec un champ
d'application très souvent parisien j'ai
bien lu il a beaucoup réfléchi à tous la
notion de métropole et surtout il a eu
le souci d'étendre son regard de ne pas
être trop exact nal puisque il a
travaillé sur en europe bien sûr il a
travaillé sur la russie il a travaillé
sur le brésil ainsi si j'ai bien compris
autrement dit son sac et son problème de
recherche c'est le lien entre les
mobilités et le développement
territorial
je peux résumer et bien sûr du coup les
modes de gouvernement
voilà donc je vais leur donner la parole
déjà été trop long je mettrais peut-être
mon grain de sel d'historiens ici ou là
dans la discussion est donc dans quel
ordre vous le souhaitez vous intervenir
finalement
alors j'ai oublié de vous dire mais
c'est décisif
vous n'avez pas à la tribune
d'économistes de sociologues
mais des géographes de souche et des
géographes qu'ils ont accompli
excellemment virer les vocations
nouvelle et moderne de la géographie qui
est quand même un travail constant avec
les collectivités avec les élus pour
essayer d'en de répondre un peu à
toutes propositions
qui sort des territoires qui sort de
leurs actes qu'ils sortent de leurs
habitants et qui doivent se traduire
d'une façon ou d'une autre en termes de
politique en termes de politiques
publiques
donc
allez on donne la période
bien merci beaucoup je vois que vos
dossiers sont parfaitement à jour 6 les
donc sur cette question de l'école des
ponts bon j'y reviendrai pas
c'est un ami vous saviez vous c'est
douloureux où ça ne l'est pas
non
mais vous voulez vraiment vous parle de
ça c'est
la première année ça s'était très bien
passé j'avais un petit groupe
d'ingénieurs et que ce pont en master
c'était vraiment extra y avait une
chinoise et puis douze français est au
bout du bout de trois mois je n'ai vu
plus que une chinoise et quatre français
alors j'écris mais qu'est ce qui se
passe ils boycottent montcourt ils sont
pas contents donc c'est les profs ses
traits narcissiques donc ça et on me dit
non monsieur pas du tout ils ont été
rachetés par des banques alors c'était
avant la crise ils ont été rachetés par
des banques est au contraire il adoré
votre cour il on était désolé de partir
mais vous comprenez quand une banque qui
vous rachète il faut y aller quoi et
donc j'ai appris à cette occasion là
comme ingénieur des ponts x-ponts ça
coûtait 70 mille euros à l'époque en
tout cas puisque la banque que
l'entreprise rembourser à peu près la
moitié du coût de l'ingénieur des ponts
alors peut-être que ça s'est calmé
depuis mai suivait alors j'ai pas trop
tenu le coup quoi si vous voulez dans
cette ambiance là c'est un peu compliqué
pour un prof de voir sa classe la moitié
de sa classe disparaître
beaucoup de robes ou d'un hors jeu peut
fermer cette parenthèse merci beaucoup
oui
peut-être que enfin je pense pas que
vous aviez me meut démenti semer les
géographes sont pas à l'aise avec la
notion de fracture mais vraiment pas du
tout à l'aise
pourquoi parce que comme jean pierre
roux l'a très bien dit fracture ça
signifie séparation ça signifie rupture
est d'une certaine manière quand on
parle de fracture des os ça signifie
immobilisations or en dépit de tout ce
que tous les mauvais souvenirs que vous
savez de la géographie quand vous avez
appris ça quand vous étiez petit la
géographie c'est une science du
mouvement c'est une science des flux
allant par exemple pour vous donner un
exemple en géographie physique on
n'utilise pas vraiment le mot fracture
en parle de failles mais qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une faille c'est la rencontre
de deux plaques donc c'est l'endroit de
justement ce produit le mouvement où se
produit le plissement et au fric et les
phares ils peuvent absolument absolument
rejouer donc ça c'est une vieille leçon
de la géographie physique les gens qui
ont observé la terre que la terre est en
permanence en mouvement et que là on
croit qu'elle la rupture en réalité
c'est du contact qui ce qui ce qui se
produit dont je garde ça de côté d'un
autre côté
ils sont que
quand on est en même temps si vous
voulez enfin les géographes sont pas
d'une cohérence vol a cessé comme tout
que les corporations s'est divisée en
plein courant etc en même temps il faut
reconnaître que cette rhétorique de la
fac de la fracture facture de la
fracture cette rhétorique de la fracture
est vieille comme la république et que
vous avez toute une série de géographes
français qui ont en même temps alimenté
cette rhétorique de l'arl de la fracture
je vous renvoie si vous avez le temps il
ya un bouquin qui est très très bien
qu'ils s'appellent les lieux de mémoire
de pierre nora dirigée par pierre nora
dans lequel il ya un article de marcel
ronck ayolo qui est un grand géographe
où il fait l'histoire de
ce qu'on appelle la ligne saint malo
genève alors la ligne saint malo genève
c'est un truc qui est apparu dès le
milieu dès le début du 19e siècle pour
caractériser la rupture entre deux
france la france industrielle et
développer du nord-est et la france
rural et sous-développé du sud-ouest
pardonnez moi je suis aussi moi je suis
tout nous avons
je suis plus gascon que berné bon
voilà savalan genève et lorsque ce qui
est très très très drôle dans l'article
de jean caillaud l'os et qui montre
comment la ligne saint malo genève se
déplace en fait au fur et à mesure de
l'histoire mais qu'elle réapparaît en
permanence dans les discours politiques
et comment aujourd'hui la ligne saint
malo genève ont fait a complètement
changé de sens puisque elle désigne
finalement d'un côté les vieux
territoires industriels qui ont du mal à
retrouver à rebondir et les espaces du
sud-ouest qui au contraire sont très
attractifs qui sait
qu'ils élisent des hommes politiques
d'une qualité
hallucinant
non alors donc il ya cette rhétorique
voilà cette vieille rhétorique de la
ligne saint malo genève tout
l'aménagement du territoire en france
s'est fondé sur un ouvrage que tout le
monde cite et que personne n'a jamais lu
heureusement d'ailleurs parce que c'est
atroce
c'est l'ouvragé de jean françois gravier
qui s'appelle paris et le désert
français si vous n'avez rien à faire je
vous engage à le lire parce que plus
pétainiste que ça tu meurs si je peux
dire
mais ce qui s'est passé alors c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire c'est que cette
cette rhétorique là encore de la rupture
de la fracture entre la métropole la
grande ville et le reste du territoire a
complètement formaté les politiques
d'aménagement du territoire pendant
vingt ou trente ans au nom du
rééquilibrage de l'equilibre de la
redistribution
j'y reviendrai parce que je pense que au
fond nous nous nous subissons
aujourd'hui finalement les contrecoups
de cette politique qui a très bien
réussi dans les années 60 mais qui
soul et enfin excusez moi moi je pense
que typiquement là l'histoire des
bonnets rouges
l'histoire des bonnets rouges c'est le
les contrecoups actuel de la réussite
d'une politique d'aménagement du
territoire des années 60 et 70
les bretons étaient extraordinaires dans
la mobilisation dans les années 60 70
ils ont réussi d'une certaine manière à
travailler avec l'état et à faire
pression fortement sur l'état pour
obtenir toute une série davantage en
termes d'infrastructures en termes
d'installation d'entreprises etc etc
sauf que une fois qu'on a délocalisé et
qu'on a installé des entreprises de main
d'oeuvre
je dirais la maintenance ou l'intendance
n'a pas suivi c'est à dire que le
travail de qualification de
modernisation d'injection en capital qui
aurait permis à ces entreprises de
prendre
les vraies dimensions de la
mondialisation ce travail a pas été fait
donc réussite dans les années 60 vingt
ans après ou trente ans après dégâts
considérables
tout ça pour dire que méfions nous
méfions nous du discours de la fracture
et de sa conséquence en terme de
rééquilibrage parce que cette notion de
rééquilibrage elle est extrêmement
problématique donc voilà ça c'était mon
premier point si vous me permettez j'en
ai un deuxième je peux
il faut savoir que
c'est pas grave
cette affaire répondait quand même à je
dirais des réalités bretonne le celib
date des années 50
pain et n'aurait pas existé sans la
puissance et la force du syndicalisme
breton la capacité des élus à prendre
tout ceci aussi en charge et
et de le traduire politiquement en
fabriquant des élites qui ont pu être du
droit de droite du centre et puis dans
dans une relative hégémonie ps depuis
les années 80 qui répandait aussi quand
même à l'impératif de modernisation et
de développement tels que ces années-là
des trente glorieuses
l'installer partout dans le pays voilà
il ya toujours donc et
ça vient d'être très bien dit il ya
toujours un aller retour il ya toujours
du mouvement dans tout ça et bien
entendu ça ne fait qu' aggraver ou
rendre plus compliquée la situation
aujourd'hui en bretagne où avec les
capacités de résistance que vous avez
vus à l'annonce la réforme territoriale
et avec les bonnets rouges et c'est ce
qui fait que le oui cette capacité de
résistance est toujours là mais en même
temps pas payés et les et les fortes et
violente est en rupture peut-être rire
fracture peut-être parce que et il n'y a
plus de respect auteur de réponse
des zélites telles qu'elles ont été
telles qu'elles ont été formés ce que ce
que je voulais dire en fait c'est que
aussi bien pour la ligne saint malo
genève que pour cette question de paris
l état français du rééquilibrage
les on voit que les situations ne sont
pas irréversibles
c'est à dire que
évidemment dans un pays grand comme la
france avec sa diversité
tous les territoires ne sont pas
toujours en phase avec
mouvement de l'histoire le mode
d'organisation de l'économie etc etc et
que donc ce qui a été extrêmement
performant un moment ne l'est plus à un
autre mais que les dés ne sont pas
complètement joué donc je pense que
aussi pour des reconstructeurs c'est
important de se dire que les d1 le jeu
n'est pas complètement n'est pas
complètement fermée que y'a de la
réversibilité possible quand on nous dit
fracture j'ai tendance à entendre
quelque chose qui est quand même assez
irrémédiable même si on peut réduire la
fracture donc c'est aussi pour ça que
j'aime pas trop le terme fracture le
deuxième point que je voulais souligner
ici vous aviez c'est ici donc si ça
t'embête que tu me dire
le deuxième round je voulais souligner
c'est que la lecture en termes de
fracture territoriale
correspond à mon avis enfin d'un point
de vue de géographes
correspond à une
comment dirais-je unis une hyper
géographe isation
de la question sociale je n'y reviens
pas parce que je pense que xavier on
dira quelques mots là-dessus mais en
tant que géographe je crois que l'une
des choses qu'on pourrait vous dire
c'est méfiez-vous du territoire et
méfiez vous de ce que vous pouvez lire
sur le territoire quand vous lisez des
chiffres qui sont un peu à plat comme ça
parce que ce que vous voyez en fait
c'est une photo c'est ce que vous voyez
c'est une photo
or ce qui nous intéresse du point de vue
de la vie des gens c'est le film et
qu'est ce que c'est que le film qu'est
ce que nous enseigne le film c'est que
en fait les gens ne sont pas du tout ou
au temps scotché et assigné à résidence
qu'on veut bien le dire ce que nous
enseigne le film quand on arrive à
suivre les trajectoires des gens et
quand on n'est pas focalisé sur les
territoires si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire ce que nous enseigne le film c'est
que au contraire 10% des français
déménagent chaque année que nous sommes
dans un système d'interdépendance
extrêmement forte des territoires que
même dans les espaces ruraux nous avons
des circulations extrêmement importantes
y compris des circulations quotidiennes
domicile travail domicile études et
c'est que nous sommes dans un monde de
mobilité que du coup effectivement les
gens qui sont peu mobiles on se retrouve
très handicapée par rapport au flux
général mais que si vous repérez les
territoires uniquement regardant les
photos successives vous ne comprenez pas
la vie des gens je vous donne un exemple
qui est tiré juste des d'ailleurs donc
donc christophe guilluy puisque c'est
quand même en gros le spectre de
christophe guilluy hand cette discussion
il vient de sortir un bouquin vous avez
vu sur les fractures françaises
déclarent mais
mais mais mais xavier en parlera en
parlera très bien les quartiers de la
politique de la ville
alors les quartiers de la politique de
la ville quand vous prenez les
indicateurs les
successifs quand vous regardez le profil
social de ces quartiers tous les dix ans
enfin au gré des recensements etc vous
dites à mon dieu quelle catastrophe la
politique de la ville a complètement
échoué parce que c'est toujours les
mêmes il ya de plus en plus d'immigrés
ils sont de plus en plus pauvres ces
secteurs sauf que depuis trente ans que
les quartiers sans politique de la ville
c'est peu les mêmes qui habitent c'est
pas les mêmes et donc
été comme notre appareil statistique
est un appareil statique qui ne nous
permet pas de savoir d'où viennent les
gens combien de temps ils sont restés là
dedans et où ils sont allés après nous
ne savons pas en réalité si la politique
de la ville est un échec ou pas tout
simplement nous ne pouvons pas le dire
nous ne pouvons pas le dire parce que
rien ne nous dit que l'existence de
quartier spécialisée dans l'accueil de
pauvres et d'immigrés constitue en soi
un handicap ou pas pour les personnes
qui le traverse et tant que nous
n'aurons pas des informations de ce type
en réalité nous n'aurons pas pour
reprendre l'expression de marc fesneau
tout à l'heure
ou pardon de françois bayrou nous
n'aurons pas les mots pour décrire la
réalité sociale c'est-à-dire france et
l'insee ou man non lindsay ne vous
demande pas l'insee vous vous fait un
diaporama là où il faudrait voir des
films voilà
la troisième chose que non elle est
simplement alors du coup même si les
chiffres de l'insee ou même raison que
j'ai défini selon la vieille
comptabilité nationale pour détruire la
comptabilité nationale c'est une
comptabilité de flux justement là c'est
ça c'est très intéressant mais alors
comment construisez vous aujourd'hui et
ça les élus s'en sont très attentifs à
cela est très demandeur comment coup
construisez vous aujourd'hui vous
géographe mais avec des économies
sociologue que celle vos indicateurs vos
voisins disent et vos indicateurs pour
mesurer pour mesurer et si on mesure
bien on trouve le moment où finalement
peut-être
votre réponse est très claire c'est ma
réponse non mais
vous normal moi je lis le christophe
ghisi il construit sans cesse des
indicateurs nouveaux voilà je me pose
des questions mais sais-tu stock
typiquement qui lui l'est que sur du
stock
c'est bon excusez moi non donc petit
point parce que moi je le fractures
françaises le titre du de la table-ronde
ici évidemment fait référence au livre
de de christophe qui lui et son livret
être est très intéressant peut-être gens
diraient quelques mots tout à l'heure
mais ils posent aux certain nombre de
problèmes c'est à dire qu'il décrit une
france périphérique qu'est ce qui
définit comme une france périphérique tu
veux bien pu vivre
son livre est intéressant mais pose
beaucoup de questions et je pense que
voilà j'ai envie de discuter ce que nous
dit frédéric guy lui il nous dit tout
d'abord quelque chose qui est tout à
fait vrai c'est que la métropolisation
ça fonctionne c'est à dire que dans les
grandes villes on a une concentration à
dire des activités les plus productifs
des activités intellectuelles du droit
de la finance de l'ingénierie et c'est
donc on a une concentration de la
richesse et de la production de richesse
dans les grandes villes et que par effet
conséquent on a donc un embourgeoisement
des villes
donc ça c'est tout à fait vrai
gentryfication gentryfication et garde
les autres visages on peut le dire en
effectif mans en anglais c'est tout
aussi bien pour ce qui est puis d'un
autre côté donc à côté cette maîtrise à
sion qui a fait économique bien bien
établie nous dit il
il diagnostique ce qu'il appelle une
france périphérique
quelle est cette france périphérique ce
nous dit il c'est 60% des français ce
sont tous les français qui vivent en
fait en dehors des 25 plus grandes aires
urbaines françaises donc tous les
français qui habitent les petites villes
les zones rurales les zones les zones
périurbaines et en fait donc c'est là où
ils raisonnent en photo qu'est-ce qui
nous isole ces territoires d'après en
super périphérique et que nous dit il il
nous dit des choses qui sont
statistiquement vrai s'il a bien pris
ses tableaux sur lindsay il nous dit que
dans ces zones ça concentre on va dire
la france populaire sont sur représentés
dans ces zones les ouvriers les employés
c'est complètement vrai ça c'est sûr ce
sont dans ces zones également que se
concentrent ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les effets négatifs de la mondialisation
c'est quand on regarde toutes les
fermetures d'usinés en lorraine en
bretagne etc c'est vrai qu'on est dans
cette france périphérique des petites
villes des campagnes août et du
périurbain lointain et puis c'est dans
ces zones également nous dit il que
s'expriment les nouvelles radicalités et
parmi les nouvelles radicalités en fait
ils s'intéressent principalement au vote
front national mais pas que il
s'intéresse également par exemple au
bonnet rouge donc voilà le portrait de
la france qu'il fait et je trouve que ce
portrait de la france est intéressant
parce qu'il est ainsi justement sur la
dimension de la de la fracture alors si
vous voulez bien parce que ce livre
très intéressant et j'ai entendu
monsieur la salle sur france culture qui
dialoguer avec monsieur monsieur guy lui
et je trouve que c'est vivre est
effectivement très important et beaucoup
de choses explique à mon avis son succès
et après je dirais selon moi pourquoi il
présente un certain nombre de dangers
par la construction même de son
raisonnement
pourquoi beaucoup de succès parce que
finalement il décrit quelque chose que
l'on ressent bien une sorte d'évolution
sociale très palpable effectivement les
centres villes se sont beaucoup
embourgeoisé il ya une paire et
organisation des classes populaires
c'est une évidence depuis une quinzaine
d'années et puis il ya eu quand même une
progression des prix immobiliers
absolument délirant 150 % d'augmentation
des prix à l'achat depuis 2000 donc
effectivement je dirais ça chasse ce
qu'ils peuvent pas se payer les
centre-villes etc donc ça c'est vrai que
ce ce cette trajectoire décrite est tout
à fait vrai il décrit aussi quelque
chose qui est tout à fait vrai c'est je
dirais dans les zones rurales mais pas
que fin dans beaucoup de zones ce qu'il
appelle une perte des repères politiques
et ça je dois dire que christophe dudit
le dit et j'ai fait avec des étudiants
une enquête à la souterraine c'est dans
la creuse c'est une petite ville de la
creuse auprès de jeunes précaires on les
a vraiment fait des entretiens longs et
c'est avec eux est quelque chose qui
nous a absolument frappé c'est que le
seul référent politique le seul qu'ils
ont c'est le front national aucun autre
c'est front national tout pas front
national le reste ne compte pas neuneu
n'est pas dans l'écran radar donc ça a
effectivement ai dit quelque chose de
vrai de tout de tout à fait doux tout à
fait inquiets de tout à fait de tout à
fait étonnant troisième chose que nous
raconte christophe guilluy et sur lequel
à mon avis on peut on peut évidemment
être attentif c'est que son argument
c'est que cette france populaire c'est
non seulement une transformation
du territoire c'est-à-dire ai dit voilà
la france pour une rural périurbaines
est devenue la france populaire et ne
dis pas que ça me dit que cette france
se sent méprisée sous représentés et il
insiste beaucoup sur l'évolution de la
sélection des élites politiques qui
effectivement quand on regarde par
exemple le profil des nouveaux élus des
nouveaux maires etc la sélection on a
effectivement on pourrait dire aussi un
embourgeoisement des élites politiques
et pas simplement des centres villes et
donc tout ça est
effectivement il nous dit plein de
choses qui sont dérangeantes etc qui
nous interroge beaucoup et beaucoup de
choses que l'on retrouve nous tous je
dirais quand canton quand on parle aux
gens votent on regarde ce qui se passe
mais cela dit sur cette dimension de la
fracture est finalement qu'est-ce qu'il
nous fait lui lui nous ressuscitons
paris et le désert français avec les
métropoles la france périphérique quoi
on a un nouveau truc un peu moi ça me
dérange pour 2,2 question de questions
majeures la première qui peut même très
dérangeante c'est qu'il nous oppose une
certaine manière les aides aux villes et
les aides au chant pur et dur comme ça
ce qui nous dit en gros c'est que dans
la métropole tout fonctionne ici il ya
sûrement des élus militants qui habitent
dans des grandes métropoles ils seront
quand même étonné de lire par exemple
que le dynamisme du marché de l'emploi
permet une intégration économique et
sociale dans les grandes métropoles y
compris des populations précaires
immigrés où il suffit de regarder un
petit peu ce qui se passe pour que ce
n'est pas totalement vrai quand même
qu'il ya effectivement dans les
métropoles un certain nombre de
quartiers excessivement je dirai où la
situation est extrêmement difficile en
termes de pauvreté mais aussi
d'intégration sociale économique et
symbolique donc là quand même un petit
peu attention il ya du mouvement dans
les quartiers de politique de la ville
insuffisamment connue il ya du mouvement
mais mêmes même s'il ya une sorte de
petite classe moyenne de 1ère ou 2ème
génération 2000 des migrants qui tout à
fait bien sûr qui s'en sort qui
s'activent et qui progresse à un bien ou
bien sûr heureusement heureusement bien
sûr et bien sûr effectivement
heureusement mais ce qui m'inquiète un
petit peu c'est que d'un côté regarde
l'évolution sur les quartiers dit des
choses pourraient être contredites mais
par ailleurs il s'intéresse pas aux
longitudinale dans les campagnes on est
enfin je dirais aussi dans la france
périphérique à des gens qui réussissent
et bien heureusement et puis quand même
plus fondamentalement whisky maps qui ce
qui m'interroge beaucoup et ce qui
m'étonne d'une certaine manière dans un
livre
peut-être c'est que finalement il en
vient fortement et ça je pense que c'est
une vraie question politique a opposé
les aides aux quartiers difficiles des
centres villes des villes des métropoles
qui se ruinent aide aux immigrés à
l'aide dans les autres territoires qui
serait une aide aux français et donc
c'est là qu'on voit quelque chose de à
mon avis extrêmement dangereux c'est
qu'on voit bien derrière ce débat
finalement c'est toujours l'idée mais
est ce que la république est pas un tout
petit peu trop généreuse cette vie des
immigrés et ça ça me gêne beaucoup parce
que finalement ça réussit des choses
qu'on a beaucoup entendu depuis que je
suis gamin par l'extrême droite et ça
c'est très bizarre que ça revienne géré
par à-coups par la géographie comme ça
ça m'embête beaucoup pour en discuter
alors la deuxième limite vraiment que je
fais beaucoup et cette analyse
finalement c'est une sorte de
superposition du social du spatial du
politique
s'ils ont reçu son topo la france
périphérique je caricature un petit peu
mais c'est ça c'est les classes
populaires donc c'est social spatiale
quoi elles sont là les classes
populaires on peut nuancer mais pourquoi
pas et puis ces classes populaires et
sont plus tentés par le front national
est ce qu'il appelle globalement les
nouvelles radicalités
moi ça me effectivement effectivement si
on regarde une carte c'est évident que
là il ya une sur représentation du vote
front national dans l'est dans les
périphéries des grandes villes dans un
certain nombre de campagnes fortement
mais je suis normand beaucoup en
normandie c'était une vraie surprise
mais en 2014 35 % dans certains villages
star donc effectivement il ya une
surreprésentation et mais je suis
toujours extrêmement embêté si vous
voulez quand on rabat finalement c'est
une sorte d'explication
qui dénie finalement une sorte
d'autonomie aux politiques c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il ya un peu plus de
gens ici qui vote du front national mais
la majeure partie des des ouvriers qui
habite dans la croix sur l'afrique ne
vote pas pour le front national et donc
ça aussi c'est quelque chose qui doit
être expliqué et qui n'est absolument
pas expliquée par monsieur dit oui et
pourtant c'est un fait majorité le vote
contre le front national par giggs wayne
donc voilà ce qui me ce qui me ce qui me
gêne un peu dans cette lecture n'en vois
bien finalement comment
cette lecture est à la fois intéressant
par les aspects et les mais elle me
semble un petit peu un petit peu
dangereuse
et puis d'ailleurs aussi une dernière
petite chose que je voudrais dire c'est
que ce débat là on pourrait dire c'est
un débat purement intellectuel où il
fait la une de marianne les revues
exclamé mais pas seulement parce que ce
débat on voit bien qu'ils influencent la
décision publique parce que à quoi on le
voit le nouveau ministère de
l'aménagement du territoire on pourrait
dire aujourd'hui s'appelle égalité des
territoires et c'est pourquoi ils ont
abaissé à égalité les territoires il me
semble qu'en fait ils ont comme il se
disait on va pas identifié politique de
la ville parce que ça veut dire qu'en
gros pour caricaturer on aide les
quartiers où il ya un grand nombre
d'immigrés donc comme on veut pas
montrer qu'on aide ces quartiers là on
va l'appeler sa égalité des territoires
comme ça on noie le poisson dans l'eau
on cache un petit peu cette cette aide
spécifique qu'on apporte pour se
soustraire à cette attaque qui ne
pourraient nous venir d'aidé trop ces
personnes là et puis par ailleurs le
techniquement mais c'est important on a
de nouveaux critères de définition des
quartiers populaires avant dans la
politique de la ville mais ça c est là
ça c'est la thèse de philippe il nous
raconte bien que dans les années 80 90
on définissait les quartiers en
difficulté et terrain des grandes
agglomérations par différents critères
qui compte de l'importance de la
population jeunes du taux de logements
sociaux et de la part de l'immigration
parce qu'on faisait l'hypothèse que
limite on faisait le constat que
l'immigration posé un certain nombre
d'enjeux notamment en matière
d'éducation parce que c'est pas pareil
d'éduquer des enfants qui parlent
français la maison et d'autre et c'est
donc on avait construit tout dispositif
de cette manière là et je dirais sous
cette pression idéologique de refuser de
dire ah mais c'est faux pas regarder
spécifiquement ça on a complètement
changé ça a été fait en 2013 je prends
la définition de 2012 va semer françois
lamy qui était mise de la ville pour
avoir comme spécificité uniquement le
critère du revenu c'est à dire on
regarde tout le reste où on est on est
face qui voulait cette dimension là
parce qu'on veut se prémunir contre
toute attaque venant j'imagine de
l'extrême droite alors je trouve que
voilà un petit peu l'analyse que je fais
qui diffuse dans l'âme dans la pensée et
dans le temps en temps dans l'action
même public et on voit bien que ce débat
là il n'est pas neutre quad c'est à dire
effectivement la façon de nommer les
mauvais dans la presse sur la manière de
conduire les politiques publiques est-ce
que ce que j'avais envie de
te dire en conclusion c'est que enfin
sur ce plan là c'est que la question de
la fracture
je partage complètement s'cusez jean
pierre rioux et philippe estève sur la
limite de ce modèle mais par ailleurs en
fait la vraie la vraie crainte c'est
effectivement faire des typologies comme
ça binaire me semble particulièrement
dangereuse parce qu'en fait il me semble
que la laque et le la réalité
territoriale est beaucoup plus complexe
et que finalement il faut peut-être de
temps en temps à accepter un peu plus de
complexité plutôt que ce décès dans ce
système binaire mais on pourrait revenir
tout allait bien merci je voudrais qu'on
sorte un peu de du commentaire de des
travaux de christophe guilluy je vous
rappelle donc il ya eu un premier livre
qui s'intitule fractures françaises au
pluriel n'est pas en 2010 il me souvient
bien qu'il sort avant-hier un livre qui
s'appelle la france périphérique sous
titre comment on a sacrifié les classes
populaires
je voudrais signaler jeu j'en ai dit un
mot tout à l'heure moi j'ai été très
frappé par la note pour terra nova de
laurent davezies et thierry pech sur la
nouvelle question territoriale je pense
qu'elle peut intéresser beaucoup
beaucoup d'élus ici présents parce que
il dit oui bien sûr à travers là je
dirais le
redécoupage territorial tel tel qui
s'annonce et il faut tenter de rendre
l'action publique plus efficace tout le
monde est d'accord il faut favoriser
toujours non pas l'égalité mais
déséquilibre peu oui des territoires qui
tiennent compte des mobilités qui comme
des flux qui tiennent compte des
allers-retours donc très bien et d'abord
préserver parce que ça c'est la vocation
républicaine
préserver l'équilibré entre blues je le
disais tout à l'heure entre performance
et solidarité entre production et
distribution ont finalement propose pour
dire les choses très simplement
alors ce qu'il dit et moi ça me touche
beaucoup parce qu il
il annonce dans cette note qu' il y
aurait fin d'une sorte de cycle
historique
l'un et l'autre laissé sentir jusqu'à
une période relativement récente
distille un compromis semblait avoir été
trouvé entre production et distribution
finalement à tel point que les écarts de
revenus par habitant entre les grands
territoires région département zones
d'emploi et rurbaine tendaient à
diminuer alors même que depuis le début
des années 1980 les inégalités de
création de richesses stand est elle à
s'accroître on savait qu'on pense et on
savait
négocier et redistribuer ce cycle est en
train de se refermer sans doute d'un
côté le processus de concentration
métropolitaine de la production
s'accélère en fabrication du pib' oui et
ceux des métropoles très bien de l'autre
le dynamique la dynamique de réduction
des disparités de revenus entre les
territoires est en train de s'inverser
et ces faits sont d'autant plus marque
fait qu'ils sont l'effet d'une profonde
mutation de notre modèle productif bien
sûr alors
sur fracture et je vais vous donner la
parole maintenant sur facture je crois
qu'on a on a à peu près 10 qu'on en
pensait à la fois du bien et du mal c
est en tout cas je crois que ce qu'il
faut bien
si nous voulons utiliser ce mot il vous
restait attentif à à quelques autres
mots qui ont été prononcés ici d'abord
je dirais mobilité la question de la
circulation de la richesse finalement ça
a été le dit le sous titre du premier
livre important de da beuzit sûr cela
n'est pas là circulent il ya une
circulation souterraines de la richesse
et pourquoi pas pourquoi n'aurions nous
pas des indicateurs sur le travail au
noir aussi bon très bien
il y à un oubli qui pour moi historien
est tout à fait dans ses discours sur
les fractures qui pour moi est tout à
fait tout à fait grave parce que et kiki
et celui ci
sait des choses que la bonne vieille
équipe d' hervé le bras ces deux
d'emmanuel todd ont redit traitera en
est cependant un livre une cartographie
sur le mystère français distilbène
si nous parlons de fractures nous
gommons tout ce qui ce qui est un
variant bas tout ce qui est
potentiellement invariants famille
habite à religion et ils disent eux
combien il y a aujourd'hui dans un souci
de proximité qui en tout le monde
relégué gens en panne bobos que c est
tout le monde la proximité et c'est dans
la proximité qu'on retrouvera noz est
finalement
sociaux et culturels et là ils disent
que t'es fais attention il ya rémanence
des espaces quasi anthropologique
si vous voulez des espaces religieux qui
sonde allure préindustrielle et
qui sont toujours là et qu'ils peuvent
aussi si on les laisse kruth si on l'est
tentent de les animer c'est toutes les
politiques patrimoniales finalement et à
ses élus pour savoir que c'est important
et surtout surtout c'est ce week-end
je trouve que raisonner sur facture en
faisant oublie totalement ou table rase
de tout ce qui est passé entre paulo j
et pourquoi pas aux auront un grand mot
passe et identitaire les choses et des
gens n'est ce pas et se re serait très
dommageable dans tout cas nous amènerait
à réagir de travers il ya un autre
domaine que nous n'avons absolument pas
abordée on ne peut pas tout dire c'est
je ne vois pas comment dans le discours
sur la flotte de fracture il y as place
pour un argumentaire d'ordre écologique
d'ordre traitant du développement
durable d'ordre traitant de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
je ne vois pas et je ne comprends pas
tout comme il y à aussi quand même eu
une vocation de l'analyse
terriblement hexagonal
très peu de points de comparaison
européens et notamment et la question
politique je le répète et notamment le
rôle de l'état le rôle combiné de l'est
de l'état des collectivités
territoriales des de l'europe et ses
directives tout ça un internaute
n'intervient pas et n'ai jamais prononcé
un grand mot centriste n'est ce pas qui
est subsidiarité
est ce que je voudrais si vous me
permettez
dire dire deux mots
politique
quand on dit mobilité
on ne dit pas évidemment que la mobilité
résout tous et c est quand on nie quand
on refuse d'utiliser le terme fracture
évidemment on ne nie pas au contraire
l'existence d'inégalités dans
l'accroissement des inégalités
on insiste au contraire d'un point de
vue politique sur ce qui doit relier
et il me semble et c'est ce qu'a dit
aussi
vous aviez que le discours de la
fracture est un discours mortifère parce
que c'est un discours qui qui est
justement enfin qui provoque de la
division et qui au fond a toujours cette
espèce de résultats consistant à dire
redistribution redistribution il faut en
donner plus à ceux qui ont moins etc or
on sait bien quand on est dans des dents
des niveaux de plafonnement des capacité
redistributive vous l'avez dit
- il semble que la responsabilité des
élus des collectivités territoriales
c'est d'être des opérateurs de mobilité
alors je m'explique il s'agit pas de
faire bouger les gens comme ça etc mais
il est clair que quand par exemple moi
dans mon village face à lille le dise
plus mais ils disent on veut garder les
jeunes je dis non jamais foutez leur un
coup de pied aux fesses et envoyez les à
l'extérieur dans le monde extérieur
qu'ils aillent chercher aider les allées
chercher la ressource dans les
métropoles dans les grandes villes
ailleurs qu'il fasse le tour de france
des transports en commun ont pesé
autrefois etc et donc c'est ça être
opérateur de mobilité alors je donne une
image un peu stupide 1 et excusez moi
parce que alors là pour le coup les
enquêtes les comparaisons
internationales le monde sur la mobilité
des personnes y compris la mobilité
internationale par exemple on se plaint
beaucoup que les français les jeunes
français s'exile à mon dieu nous perdons
les jeunes français etc ils reviennent
et c'est la grande caractéristique de la
france et même des pays européens c'est
que effectivement une partie des jeunes
gens s'expatrient beaucoup il au fond
c'est une très bonne chose et ensuite
ils reviennent ce qui est tout à fait
différente des pays en voie de
développement etc etc et je pense que
nous devons raisonner dans les
territoires de la même façon que nous
devons raisonner à l'échelle de la
nation c'est à dire que au fond notre
meilleur système d'insertion dans le
monde c'est notre capacité à faire
circuler à faire circuler les personnes
à opérer cette espèce de métissage et et
de rencontres au terme duquel il ya un
retour avec retour sur investissement
d'une certaine façon le développement
rural s'est pas rajouter toujours plus
de l'argent des équipements faire manger
des salles des fêtes et des ronds points
à des à des petites communes qui n'en
peuvent plus c'est leur permettre de
s'inscrire dans des systèmes de réseaux
grâce auquel elles vont pouvoir faire
bénéficier leurs habitants de ressources
qui ne peuvent pas pour plein de raisons
s'inscrire dans ces territoires là et
donc et j'en termine par là il me semble
que c'est un changement de nature même
c'est le problème de la réforme
territoriale c'est même pas un problème
de mécano c'est même pas un problème
d'échelle territoriale un peu quand même
mais c'est aussi beaucoup un changement
de nature de l'exercice du pouvoir local
c'est à dire qu'il faut arrêter de
penser les territoires comme de petites
nations dans lesquelles il s'agit de
garder la population de garder les
jeunes etc et d'être au contraire dans
des logiques de porosité et d'ouverture
et vous parliez de développement durable
tout ce qui est développement durable
c'est-à-dire la circulation des espèces
les trames vertes les trames bleues eh
bien c'est exactement ça c'est des
territoires qui deviennent traverser et
qui deviennent opérateur voo flux voilà
oui mais pour que le raisonnement soit
complet il faut aussi qu'en échange il
n'y ait pas constamment demande de
couverture sociale et ou autre et ou
culturelles et de l'ordre étatique qui
n'est ce pas bon
bah oui mais oui c'est très facile à
dire précisément pour les régions
périphériques
ou là ou là sur huit tient d'abord à la
location x y ou z
c'est le système territorial français
qui a entretenu la guerre de tous contre
chacun où chaque territoire et ils ont
bien qu'ils entendent et en été les 6
mois dernier a entretenu la
redistribution
et et les uns contre les autres pour
obtenir
la redistribution nationale c'est ça
alors c'est très efficace c'est
magnifique c'est tout ce que vous voulez
c'est vrai que c'est un système
d'égalité des terrils territoriale qui
est sans doute unique au monde parce que
redistribuer entre 36000 communes est
arrivé à réduire le quart des inégalités
fiscales de départ c'est quand même une
belle performance mans mais sa fabrique
de la guerre de tous contre chacun
l'enjeu aujourd'hui des collectivités
territoriales c'est bien de se
désintoxiquer de l'état et de travailler
ensemble c'est la question des
solidarités horizontale c'est ça la
circulation seller solidarité
horizontale et quand on voit aujourd'hui
quel est le fond ou est-ce que ça va
redistribuer maintenant enfin marc
fesneau le sait mieux que moi c'est le
fpjc c'est à dire cesser cette logique
de solidarité entre territoires et non
plus de cette logique dans laquelle les
territoires vont s'adresser à l'état
pour obtenir des avantages spécifiques
il faut sortir de ça oui tout ça
implique une révolution profonde des
mots services publics et des mots école
parce que du coup une excuse mais le
mécanisme du fifty fifty joue toujours
et a cédé lui qui le sound va toujours
autant de services publics kabore
toujours autant de collèges qu'avant
toujours etc etc non parfait je voudrais
donner la parole maintenant à isabelle
le bal
est pourquoi je demande leur donne la
parole parce que
elle est une de ces nouvelles nous reste
est resté une de ses nouvelles et luce
vous avez vous allez entendre la
première adjointe
du maire de quimper
après une victoire qui vaut d'être salué
je crois qu'on peut l'applaudir
et elle est plus qu en voisine
elle va nous dire comment unis lui réagi
à notre discours plus ou moins plus ou
moins scientifiques vous ou nous
informer plus ou moins cohérent nous
sommes bien d'accord sur la notion de
fracture comment comment vivez-vous sa
virée au quotidien parce qu'en plus vous
présidez une communauté d'agglomération
je vous en prie je vais commencer par
indiqué nerma des miles donc bienvenue
en bretagne à tous ceux qui viennent
d'ailleurs parce que la langue bretonne
ça fait aussi partie d'une identité d'un
territoire humain donc effectivement je
suis pas tout à fait nouvelle est nu
c'est mon quatrième mandat à quimper qui
est la capitale de département du
finistère qui a des frontières communes
avec saint pierre et miquelon
avec les cosses
avec l'ensemble des îles de martinique
est aussi nouvelle calédonie donc c'est
une bretagne qui est sur les grandes
ondes
et pourquoi j'ai choisi un mot breton
pour parler des bonnes aux houches parce
que ce ne suis pas d'accord avec les
propos qui ont été énoncées pour vous
dire d'abord que les bonnets rouges
c'est parti la même semaine de notre
compagnie toile on recevait jean
lassalle il y avait les bonnes et 11
donc c'est un peu des écoutes campagne
que je vous raconte aussi
et
vous avez oublié de dire la devise est
le mot d'ordre de rassemblement c'est un
mot breton qui était réseau ray ça veut
dire trop c'est trop et qu'est-ce qui a
été l'élément déclencheur c'est
l'application de l'écotaxe en bretagne
il y avait eu un débat parlementaire
pour dire qu'il fallait pas qu'on
applique de la même manière sur les
régions périphériques que nous étions
parce qu'on nous appelle de fini
stérilisation on a doit plein de gros
mots pour dire qu'on est très loin de
tout
c'était de l'application l'écotaxe de
manière identique en bretagne alors que
90% de l'économie bretonne se fait avec
des transports qui font moins de 100 km
vous allez allez de l'abattoir
voilà à la gare et c'est donc les
camions des petites entreprises
bretonnes souvent familiales
aller à être taxés dix fois plus que les
autres régions françaises donc les
bonnets rouges c'est parti de là dans un
contexte économique de l'agroalimentaire
en crise en mutation on avait des
milliers de salariés mis dehors chez gad
aux abattoirs tilly et cetera donc un
contexte désespérance sociale un
contexte acculturation non à la langue
bretonne nos moyens aussi pour réunifier
la bretagne les moyens institutionnels
ans qu'on voulait nous faire une grande
région
forte économiquement au niveau européen
donc il y avait un contexte économique
social institutionnel et des phénomènes
culturels
moi je vais vous dire que les bonnets
rouges j étais comme beaucoup d'élus
centristes comme beaucoup d'élus de tous
bords alors chut du monde du livre alors
j'ai un copain anthropologue de bordeaux
qui m'a appelé j'ai plutôt de bauchi
mahdi raté en train de devenir extrême
droite après j'ai une amie
bibliothécaire de paris qui médian est
en train de devenir extrême gauche non
pas du tout j'étais ni extrême droite et
extrême gauche
ni extrême non plus parce que ce qui
s'est passé à quimper c'est qu'il y a
des gens de tous les âges et de toutes
les professions qui se sont donné la
main et c'est la seule image qu'on n'a
pas vu à la et puisque les journalistes
ne l'ont pas pris d'avoir le délégué la
cgt des marins de commerce de bresse
serrant la main avec la déléguée fo
chegag avec un conseiller municipal ump
ou un artisan un peu poujadiste on va
dire des côtes d'armor tout ça c'était
en fait très fraternel et c'est une
réponse non par la fracture mal à
fragmentation c'est un refus d'une voir
françois disait il ya longtemps en se
délite laon se fragmente
c'est une réponse positive à un refus de
la fragmenter fragmente c'est pas la
fracture donc on a envie de travailler
ensemble on a envie de défendre une
région qu'on aime donc c'était un
message plutôt positif c'était une
réponse positive en tout cas ce que je
voulais dire aussi sur le territoire
notre problème c'est le désenclavement
dans ce contexte il y avait on n'aura
pas tgv si c'est pas la région bretagne
et les villes qui paye l'arrivée du tgv
donc par rapport à d'autres régions de
france ont été désavantagés donc nous on
a dit si on n'a pas de tgv ou un avion
la ligne quimper paris ces 600 euros
donc comment faire du développement
économique et même d'envoyer nos
étudiants erasmus pendant leurs études
va londres ou à madrid on pouvait pas
l'avion était devenue une problématique
donc pour nous ça c'est un enjeu et
l'état y la république ne donne aucun
moyen d'aménagement de désenclavement
aérien
la bretagne
après ou un mot sur les finances
publiques donc moi effectivement je suis
première adjointe d'une ville de 60 7000
habitants à peu près 90 millions d'euros
de budget et vice président de
l'agglomération se charger lancer mon
supérieur et du personnel c'est une
entreprise de 1900 salariés
où on a peut-être gagné parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de protocole syndical où on a
peut-être gagné parce que ccs il ya 2
167 logements d'urgence qui sont occupés
depuis plus de dix ans donc c'est que
c'est plus de l'urgence c'est qu'il ya
une mauvaise gestion des logements
sociaux
dans la politique urbaine
alors qu'est ce qu'on a on a gagné parce
qu'on a fait une liste d'union
centristes ont effet 15% au premier tour
et on a gagné avec une liste ump au
deuxième tour en abandonnons nos
étiquettes politiques mois pour moi
c'est un élément de la négociation c'est
pas de logo c'est une autre équipe qui
se présente on a gagné en disant qu'on
n'augmentera pas les impôts toujours
raisonné ras-le-bol fiscale c'est un
frein au développement économique que
les collectivités continuent à augmenter
les impôts c'est ce qui s'était fait
dans le précédent mandat et pour y
arriver mais on a pris des décisions
c'est moi 10 % le budget 2015
-10% dépense donc ça fait ça fait du mal
parce que quand vous enlevez à la scène
nationale 200000 euros somme c'est trois
emplois qui saute donc c'est les
subventions aux associations
mais finalement on trouve des économies
et on réinvestit les politiques
publiques d'une autre manière on a une
adjointe au maire spatiale est là mais
elle est pas loin
qui est avec nous on l'a intitulé
nouvelle gouvernance des politiques
publiques c'est à dire qu'il faut tout
réinventer remettent tout en cause en
faisant des économies donc on va faire
un budget avec -10% parce que les
dotations d'état pour nous c'est moins
33 millions - 33 millions d'euros son
mandat donc ça voulait dire 14 %
d'augmentation d'impôts c'est impossible
donc on va baisser les dépenses
publiques et en faisant cet exercice est
une remise en cause
ça n'empêche pas effectivement de faire
du dialogue social ça n'empêche pas de
préserver l'emploi public ça n'empêche
pas de préserver les services à la
population au contraire
de faire quand même des politiques
d'innovation
mais on va vers la un autre mot si on
entendait le maire de guidel sur l'étape
donc pour nous c'est un million d'euros
par an l'étape
et à quimper 50% de la population
scolaire et dans l'enseignement
catholique donc lancé magazine 0 là il
ya un problème d'équité des politiques
publiques pourquoi un enfant un élève
qui est scolarisé dans l'enseignement
catholique à quimper n'aurait pas lui
aussi droit à dix animateurs pour
apprendre à jouer aux échecs ou au le
siège en animation un périscolaire
donc il ya un problème d'équité dans les
nouvelles politiques publiques qui est
un problème de courage de baisser
effectivement des dépenses pour les ré
orienter vers l'emploi les bonnets
rouges c'est ça aussi c'est à dire on
veut vivre et travailler en bretagne on
veut du boulot ici un mot sur les
politiques puisque vous avez parlé des
politiques urbaines s'assoit l'anru ou
alors la nar il n'y a plus d'argent ya
plus d'argent c'est à dire qu'on a
engagés sur la rénovation l'aide à la
pierre la transition énergétique les
élus connaissent ça là les programmes de
l'anah l'état a dit engagé des dossiers
nous on a engagé les dossiers il n'y a
pas un rond en face c'est à dire que
l'état va nous demander à nos
collectivités de repayer sa politique en
matière d' aides à la pierre de
rénovation des logements insalubres et
la rénovation urbaine donc là on est
dans des effet de ciseau extrêmement
extrêmement dur de change monde de
changement de politique publique où il
va falloir et courageux et où il fallait
innover c'est ce que je voulais dire
équité et puis
l'imagination pourrait inventer autre
chose dans cette
salle on voulait faire un jumelage avec
les cosses s'il avait gagné au oui mais
on fera quand même ça pense
donc voilà bon gars que je voulais
témoigner en tout cas mais les bonnets
rouges sais c'est pas tel qu'on l'a vu à
la télé c'est vraiment un pro une
problématique d'une taxe supplémentaire
qui n'apporte rien ni en termes
d'environnement parce que ça fait pas
conduire les camions moins longtemps sur
le territoire ni en termes économiques
donc les voyous c'est d'abord le nom à
une taxe qui nous semblait ni économique
ni écologique
et là dessus les bretons étaient tous
solidaires je peux me permettre une
remarque
ces bonnets rouges je vais faire une
remarque un peu à la guilde ses bonnets
rouges sont hors métropole
non pas du tout je dis que ces petites
et moyennes villes rurales perry rural
artisanat industrie agroalimentaire en
difficulté etc mais c'est pas dans la
logique globale is able et productive
tels que le libéralisme nous la présente
n'est ce pas c'est pas un jugement de
valeur ce que je dis c'est hors
métropole ses ordres micropole
produisant d'ancêtres dans cet immense
territoire là c'est n'est pas né à
nantes ni rennes on est bien d'accord
2 alors je vous en prie on a encore eu
que quelques minutes pour quelques
questions je vous en prie on va vous
apporter un micro faust est juste qu ont
complété ce qu'a dit isabelle
oui alors moi je suis erwan balanant je
suis
rapport celui-ci gbe conseiller
municipal à quimperlé alors moi j'ai
j'ai pas gagné ça ne s'est pas passé
loin mais j'ai pas gagné et le maire est
resté vain et socialistes à quimperlé
juste sur la question des bonus bon je
me lève je marche
sur la question des bonnets rouges
moyens il ya eu certaines choses qui
m'ont gêné sur les bonnets rouges donc
j'ai pas complètement rejoint et mais on
partage un certain nombre de choses
les bonnets rouges sont quand même le
symbole aussi de quelque chose avait
parlé du celib
dans les années 50 en bretagne les
bretons se sont fédérés autour d'un
courant de pensée qui était l'autre 1
c'était des gens qui étaient issus du
mutualisme du co-operative ct ct nous
c'est notre famille politique
le centre en partie à idées et des curés
démocrates et des curés démocrates et
des curés démocrate et quand maison les
choses vont s'apprend ils ont ils ont
pris ils ont pris quand même un chemin
qui a été effectivement de d'aller
chercher avec les dents comme dit comme
disait un comme disait un ancien
président de la république futur
président d'une grande d'une nouvelle
famille politique c'est ce qu'il a dit
tout à l'heure ils ont été chercher ça
avec les dents mais après ils en ont
fait quelque chose ils ont eu du retour
ils ont eu du retour mais après ils ont
ce que ce que moi je dit fédérer l'aîné
cnrj mobiliser les talents et je pense
que l'enjeu pour les territoires l'enjeu
pour chacun des territoires que ce soit
la région bretagne on parle de la
bretagne on peut parler de champagne
ardenne on peut parler d'aquitaine
aujourd'hui l'enjeu est de créer des
écosystèmes et de trouver la bonne
comment dire le bon territoire pour
justement mobiliser ses énergies
et fédérer ses talents parce que en
bretagne on a eu une politique qui a été
une politique de la subvention est une
politique pendant les 2 puis c'est quoi
le cadre de plans et de la région et
déchets le drian 2004 81 18 le
département du finistère passe du
centrisme la droite modérée du centrisme
au ps et on a eu un changement je moi je
le sens c'est l'analyse maintenant un
changement de vision de la chose
politique on était sur la distribution
de la subvention alors que moi je suis
persuadé que l'homme politique est la
femme politique doit être justement ce
mobilisateur d'énergie et ce fédérateur
de talents et ça si on n'a pas ça et ça
c'est dans des carnets de route qu'on a
aujourd'hui que mark nous donne de
reconstruire la france est c'est notre
rôle on va devoir inventer des nouvelles
choses on pourra plus avoir des
subventions qui vont tomber il faut
reprendre recréer des écosystèmes locaux
alors vous n'avez pas de vous avez cité
un girofle nous on a un géographe en
bretagne qu'on aime bien c'est jean
ollivro et jean ollivro justement il
explique bien qu'il faut créer ces
choses là parce que sur la
métropolisation qui après je je je
passerai la parole
moi j'ai pas lu le livre dont vous
parliez enfin pour moi la
métropolisation quand même en termes de
développement durable on est ce qu'il ya
de plus éloignées en termes d'efficience
et d'efficacité
la métropolisation ça détruit beaucoup
de choses en terme de de coûts et gains
énergétiques même si on arrive à avoir
des économies enfin ce que dit ollivro
c'est que le plus petit c'est mieux moi
je suis pas dans le small is beautiful
nécessairement mais il pense que des
entités des noyaux comme il dit plus
petit voile à branoux nos villes on ad
on a un maillage quimper qui après 10
des blocs de 10000 habitants qui se sont
organisés en intercommunalité et ça
fonctionne assez bien mais voilà lui ses
multiples modèles assez multipolaire
donc
la question de la métropolisation moi je
suis désolé j'ai vécu à paris à la fin
de mes études et au début de ma vie
professionnelle j'ai pas eu l'impression
qu'en termes de développement durable la
ville soit efficiente que ça quand je
dis développement durable c'est en terme
environnemental mais aussi en terme
social
le modèle social de la ville où on est
un peu des sociabiliser de son voisin
j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit le
meilleur modèle de vie quoi donc on a
beaucoup de travail à faire mais je
pense qu'il faut que ça passe justement
sur la la question des entités
territoriales l'ours et voilà le le
découpage a été refait pour moi il a été
refait je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
n'importe comment je pense que si on
avait voulu que ça soit né si on avait
voulu que ce soit un échec on n'aurait
pas fait mieux 1 parce que oui des
régions parce que faire des supers
région pour nous faire croire que ça va
mieux marcher faire des super belle
région effectivement ça interdit la
disparition des départements
on va avoir une région aquitaine
ils vont se réunir ou tous ses
conseillers généraux
alors alors si si on va faire on va mais
non mais voilà quoi et à côté de ça on a
des régions qui sont des régions
complètement qui ont une identité une
histoire qu'on regroupe pas alors
évidemment pour moi je que la bretagne
reste à quatre départements c'est
n'importe quoi
moi j'ajouterais qu'il ya plus grave
peut-être aussi et qui est en plein dans
notre discussion c'est que ce
redécoupage nous ce rassemblement du
feuilleté où cet effeuillage du
feuilleté si je puis dire se fait sans
que jamais l'état central je crois que
c'est alain rousset au nom des
présidents de région qui l'a dit très
bien ne dit jamais ce qu'il concède à
l'occasion de cette de cette réforme
territoriale qu'est quelles
responsabilités nouvelles qui est
qu'elle marche de latitude nouvelle
hilton ou pas depuis paris autrement dit
on on se rejoue le paris province
anti
justin moscou venir sur l'espèce de de
flexibilité social et culturel aussi
d'une de la territorialisation en
bretagne ça a des effets européen
considérable la place centrale de
cracovie je vous signale la première
maison qu'on voit c'est la maison de la
bretagne
j'avais une demande de parole par là bas
madame vous en prie et on pourra
peut-être après canclaux françois
je vais dire à mon père
je vous en prie
bon bon bon soir en fait c'était deux
questions réflexion en fait la première
par rapport au bonnet rouge quand vous
avez dit que c'était le résultat d'un
l'aménagement du territoire réussi alors
il se trouve que il ya longtemps j'ai
fait un peu de géographie d'aménagement
du territoire et pour moi il me semble
que ça n'a pas été jusqu'au bout et que
du coup il ya il manquait quelque chose
pour que ça pour que la bretagne puisse
réellement
comment dire l'idée du développement du
territoire de la bretagne c'était
qu'elle était un peu elle manquait de
route elle manquait de l'industrie ont
donc et de pas mal de choses il fallait
les dp et et quand je suis un peu étonné
que vous me disiez que c'est la réussite
d'une potence de vin mauvais réseau
routier un nom il est bon le réseau
routier maintenant breton mais alors
pourquoi comme on explique que les
bretons se soit réveillée et lui
manifester leur mécontentement
tout d'un coup ils sont passés de
beaucoup d' aide de l'état à jeu
caricaturise un peu hein je ne suis pas
géographe je ne suis plus et que j'ai eu
un tout petit peu fait des études de
géographie mais comment est ce que vous
expliquez que entre une région qui a
reçu beaucoup dead qui en avait besoin
et qui en a bénéficié qui a bien utilisé
ces aides là et aujourd'hui des bonnets
rouges qui disent non stop c'est stop -
il ya quelque chose je ne comprends pas
qu est ce qui s'est passé comme pour moi
la russie s'est pas totale c'est
toujours la métropole et les autres
aussi en termes d'éducation par exemple
la redistribution
du central vers la bretagne a été
excellente au point de faire de
l'académie de rennes et je le sais
je sais ça parfaitement oui non non non
c'est pas un jeu me signale quand même
que l'académie de rennes est
probablement la première académie de
france en excellence scolaire en
réussite aux examens et bordeaux au parc
d'accord d'accord bon françois bayrou
non je voulais et on lèvera la séance je
voulais pas intervenir mais
je bouillais en entendant des choses pas
de vous mais des textes que vous
analysiez
d'abord les bonnets rouges moi je suis
assez proche de ce que isabelle fiset
alors pour une raison complètement
contingentes accidentelle c'est que le
maire de carey qui a lancé le mouvement
avait signé pour moi en 2007
et cela et c'était très intéressant de
voir ça alors je sais bien que il ya
toutes les évolutions mais quelqu'un qui
a partagé un court bain
avec vous un moment ou un autre de sa
vie c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas un
étranger donc j'ai fait attention j' ai
goûté me suis pas laissé entraîner par
les en effet les caricatures médiatique
qui sont assez nombreuses sur ce genre
de sujet et ce qui m'a frappé c'est le
sentiment de fraternité que tu évoquais
isabelle trans classe
transcourants trans responsabilité
certainement dans une révolte
certainement infondée par un certain
nombre d'attitudes mais quelque chose
qui soude est alors que tout le reste
nous divise
et pour un certain nombre
ressentent que ça les écrase divise et
sa écran
ce mouvement là que je relis tout à fait
aux indigne à des espagnols et à des
mouvements de cet ordre il a évidemment
une très grave difficulté à affronter
c'est que il n'a pas de débouché
politique
et c'est toute la limite des événements
sociaux que nous vivrons dans les années
qui viennent
autrefois les révolutions débouchait sur
des changements même brutaux de
gouvernants et je crois que ça ne va pas
être qu'on va être devant une réalité
sociale et politique nouvelle qui est
qu' il peut y avoir des mouvements qui
ne débouchent sur rien on l'a vu en
espagne un million et demi de personnes
et pas de débouchés donc ceci est une
question démocratique pour le coup c'est
très compliqué à analyser faut inventer
des réponses ont mené à pain
deuxième chose qui m'a fait réagir moi
je suis pas la tête d'une métropole met
enfin à l'échelle de chez nous
une ville de 80 mille habitants une
ensemble urbain de 160000 ça fonctionne
comme une métropole avec une université
avec je suis absolument désaccord avec
ceux qui affirment que les métropoles ça
va bien
parce que ça a été tout à fait dit par
erwan
des métropoles pour ceux qui sont pas
dans le mouvement c'est beaucoup de
solitude
et c'est pour nous une tâche mais il ya
beaucoup d'élus enfin ils sont à
l'extérieur mais qui sont venues avec
moi c'est une tâche fondamentale que de
reconstruire du lien le plus proche
possible
sans dépenser et sans subventionner des
petits place des petits commerces des
bancs enfin des choses qu'ils fassent
qu'on puisse se rencontrer
problématique et d'armes pour les
transports urbains et toute cette
affaire là ne croyez pas que le monde
que jean lassalle décrit si bien des
ceux qui sont out les outsider comme on
dire en anglais
ne croyez pas que le monde des du rural
lointain du rural profond du périurbain
éloignés ne croyez pas qu'il soit
différent du monde du coeur des villes
en dehors de strates sociales qui
évidemment participe à la culture et qui
elles vont bien ça c'est tu sais la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire je
réserve je ferai dans le discours de
dimanche un petit paragraphe sur le
l'indécence
du pseudo découpage des régions nouvelle
en france l'indécence le l'absurdité le
manque profond
le manque profond
de sens
de ce qu'est une région car une région
lorsque de gaulle en a évoqué l'idée ne
région c'est les provinces il faut une
identité faut quelque chose qui nous
réunissent parce que à quoi ça sert de
délégués du pouvoir si vous le délégué à
une entité qui n'existe pas
quidam c'est la logique de la région
programme qui n'a pas avant même de
gaulle oui mais comme il ya plus de
programmer mais moi y'a bien programme
ya plus de régions c'est n'importe quoi
c'est la logique absurde de plus c'est
gros et mieux c'est et moi je vous dis
plus c'est gros plus ça coûte cher ça je
suis absolument certain
et le lite est de prétendre que c'est
une région quand vous mettez dans le
même triangle paul limoges et bressuire
il faut quoi
1400 kilomètres pour relier les trois
villes dans le triangle on se fout du
monde y comprennent rien ou alors ils
veulent envoyer un modèle artificielle
qui est un modèle de mini état sans
identité sans moyens avec d'ailleurs des
compétences incertaine et donc je trouve
que s'il y a et s'étend à quoi il faut
faire très attention je le dirai dans le
discours de dimanche je pense le mot de
réforme est un mot piégé parce que
qu'est ce que j'en ai à faire d'une
réforme qui aggrave la situation moi je
veux des réformes qui améliorent la
situation life en semblant de faire une
réforme je crois pour dire à bruxelles
qui font quelque chose ils font
exactement le contraire il ruine l'idée
que nous pouvons avoir des pouvoirs de
proximité c'est à dire pour le citoyen
de la prise en main de son propre destin
locales et régionales comme il prend en
main son destin national
bien merci
nous clôturons de la séance